hey what's up guys I'm QB HD here and
this is the brand new HTC 10 force
impressions as a new flagship smartphone
it's a hardware and software package
that I think is pretty promising so this
is what we're working with here first of
all this is definitely HTC so full
unibody metal jacket again from top to
bottom and it gives it that premium feel
were used to and you only really hear
about premium feel when there is usually
either glass or metal involved Samsung
being the one that likes to use a lot of
glass HTC for the metal lovers and it
feels good in the hand like a solid
chunk of metal should and they got a lot
of the little things right - I like the
button placement the ridged power button
on the side below the volume buttons is
nice for identifying it and of course
HTC heard we like chamfers so they gave
us a chamfer like no other all the way
around the back of this device
nice big shiny beveled edge but the
sides are also still flat so it's pretty
easy to hold and around the front you
have a 5.2 inch quad HD display and then
capacitive buttons surrounding a
fingerprint sensor slash home button in
the chin pretty common look right now
and the glass sort of wraps around the
front as one big sheet of slightly
curved edges so it's definitely a pretty
high-end feel and on the inside it is
high-end - like I said it's a flagship
so you have a Snapdragon 820 chip 4
gigabytes of RAM and a 3000 milliamp
hour battery plus you do have expandable
storage again in the form of a micro SD
card slot there's also a USB type-c port
at the bottom and now you're probably
wondering since this is an HTC phone
what's good with the speakers like is
there no massive stereo front facing
speaker no you do not have that but you
still have a system that HTC is calling
boom sound which is a stereo speaker
system of a woofer on the bottom for the
lower frequencies and a smaller front
facing speaker up top for the higher
frequencies and they work in tandem I
thought this was an interesting solution
to a problem that I'm not really sure
anyone actually had but so far it sounds
decent again it's no stereo front-facing
pair but it sounds pretty good now the
camera this is also something HTC has
clearly been struggling with for a
little bit this year again on paper it's
pretty promising it's rocking a 12
megapixel camera
with an F 1.8 aperture and oh is and
pretty large pixels 1.5 5 microns so
it's a big enough sensor for them to
call it an ultra pixel to camera and it
should be pretty quick with laser
autofocus and a fast camera app and yeah
this is definitely something I'm going
to be testing pretty often for the full
review I have high hopes for it but yeah
right now it seems solid and the
front-facing camera is a 5 megapixel
wide-angle shooter again with F 1.8 and
with oh is again as well so you can get
those super studies selfies and then HTC
did something I really like in a
software department first of all it's
definitely an overall cleaner version of
HTC's skin on top of Android it's more
vanilla it has this more material design
look with a lot of the stock apps and
the settings etc and then they worked
with Google on this phone to reduce the
number of duplicate apps that you get
out the box that do the same thing I've
talked about this on previous phones
Samsung in particular they'll have like
two apps installed on every phone to do
pretty much everything to email apps to
texting apps to web browsing apps to of
everything and Google already makes most
of their stock apps from Nexus phones
available in the Play Store so what HTC
did was essentially remove any duplicate
app that they don't need that Google
already makes so the default calculator
app on this phone is the Google
calculator the default calendar is
Google Calendar when you're taking
photos with the camera and then you go
to view them
the default gallery app is Google photos
so I think it's awesome that they worked
with Google to pull this off I'm sure
carriers will still find a way in the
u.s. to mess this up with all their
pre-installed bloatware but I like this
step so Bravo HTC now you might be
thinking HTC if you're just going to go
out Google e on us why not just go full
Nexus well they still offer their own
stuff with this software as well so some
fun custom launcher layout stuff you get
personal audio profiles with the super
high-end 24-bit DAC in this phone which
is dope and some battery optimization on
top of quick charge 2.0 and even Apple
AirPlay audio streaming right out the
box native support that's definitely a
first on Android phone so yeah HTC 10
like I said is a pretty promising
package I will be testing of course all
this stuff including the higher-end
headphones that come in the box for the
full review so definitely stay tuned for
that and we'll figure out if this really
the phone to save HTC thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys the
next one peace